[Music]
in the floor is lava and news Oh
oh my god for else I put my feet up me
too
submitted by John John loves food I love
with Tim Hawaii's Big Island volcano has
already destroyed a huge part of the
island and scientists don't know when it
will stop oh [ __ ] I was like me Big
Island
yeah the volcano still active so it's
been active for thirty thirty years how
do you kill time when that's going on
you know like what do you like when lava
is just coming out or you can't be
scared the whole time you know like do
you
you've act like cards what what do you
do once you've evacuated is somewhere
safe
you know how do you you know pass the
time arm wrestle wrestle short though
that's true yeah how do you have play
cards probably do the same [ __ ] because
Hawaii is just like an island so they're
probably doing the same exact stuff like
on the other side of the island yeah
maybe I'll wrestle next is good you have
like a huge tournament yeah see who's
the best and that evacuation zone yeah
they actually have that really evac zone
no back zone champs
yeah no like our wrestling tournaments
oh yeah like the one with Sylvester
Stallone our powerlifting meets yeah
they have like a whole setup and
everything with pads and like a ref all
that and I just watched that movie back
in the day yeah
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] tight dude yes it
I got a watch or was it called
arm-wrestle Stallone oh I don't know but
it was one with him and then whoever was
the limits on me yeah whoever won run
like won this dope ass [ __ ] like
semi-truck but that would help him with
his business I remember yeah yeah they
were all truckers indeed yeah and he's
all jacks there's a lot of stuff that I
thought was good he had that fat friend
that was like big but he looked the same
so it was around the same time as Rambo
so I just thought it was Rambo who just
drove probably rent out of the Rambo 5
yeah
so young I didn't know like he didn't
reenlist and he was like this out
working it did always seem like that
with Stallone it always seemed like he
was just kind of like Rambo what
yeah he's Rambo now he's driving a truck
now he's boxing it's just the same guy
and all that yeah that's weird because a
lot of the characters that he played
they were idiots yeah I mean they're
very like dumbed down stupid people so
for the longest time I thought his Rocky
accident was how he spoke hmm and so
like you know we got hold of it
it's not super much different I didn't
know they were I didn't know they were
idiots
it's pretty know if you see that I got
it right he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah he's a loser on Rocky
but no I was a child so you don't know
like what I'm saying cuz your IQs like
low as a child
thank you that's how he really talked no
in the if you listened and was less I'm
still rocking uh like it's been a while
right is that well rocky if you look at
rocky in every single movie he talks
more and more like an idiot because of
all those head trauma stuff yeah so when
he first talked is like you know edging
like I did you I did it you know exactly
and then all of a sudden later on he's
just what the yeah he's just guessing
bowels yeah he's making noises at that
point but then I assume that that's how
he spoke as normally but he doesn't talk
like that no oh then I didn't pay
attention yeah
so if you watching also now is his role
yeah so if you watch him at tango and
cash he just speaks normally oh wow
cuz he got the help no that was a
character he was playing so like I
assume that's how he spoke as a normal
person but it wasn't it was his
character in Rocky I feel like it's how
he spoke he was ya know he had yeah but
how he speaks in Rocky and how he speaks
in Pride is down is completely that
balls positive where how about your face
becomes a scrotum
Oh Fozzie where he comes and it just
ball just contracted stays there like
that just so this right now you remember
the ShamWow guy did the soul he has
Bell's palsy passed away right Cotton's
I think because that's what killed him I
think is that Ron Popeil guy still alive
who's that what we're talking about the
Hawaiian looking oh yeah yeah I was
always like watching this [ __ ] every day
I was like this is this is nature Wow
Gary swallowing cars of [ __ ] oh my god
moving yeah and it'll just eat a car huh
mm-hmm
slowly no already it's already consumed
35 structures and it has covered an
equivalent of more than 75 football
fields filled dad that will suck if like
your house was the one that's hip and
everyone else is fine yeah there's a lot
of homes like 26 homes 35 structures
here we go that's [ __ ] lava dude oh
yeah look at that it's eating that car
man Oh Martha or qd2
yeah that should eat some [ __ ] opens and
breaks an entering matter what to be
honest with you I thought the fence the
defense was gonna win I thought was
gonna stop it dude get the [ __ ] out man
yeah that's it's like across the street
from a car and I'm thinking why doesn't
anyone just run in there turn on the key
and drive it off and there's just people
standing around it and it slowly [ __ ]
consumes it you know the cool thing is
though volcanic ash high nutrition
nutrients a lot of plants after I don't
know yep yeah and they'll use some of
that charcoal they'll use it in like all
kinds of facial scrubs and
- even ice cream you can make you can
put it in ice cream yeah started that
[ __ ] sir really yeah no job really
he owns the ice cream shop yeah in
Westwood no further [ __ ] oh they're
the ones that copied no there's a lot
people are copy much the one in k-town
if you want try the original spot that's
my place Wow I'll go there what's it
called its called drips and swirls trips
and swirls that sounds like a escort
service it could be oh it absolutely
could be but it's just well a lot of
escorts have um post nasal drip mmm oh
okay yeah oh no that at the same time
cuz a lot of people on the call craft
post nasal drip that's true huh yeah
maybe like you always have it like
forever
I know some YouTube seniors that have
that [ __ ] really YouTube's singers mm
you think they're friendly and Disney
but they're cocaine addicts the most
Disney's [ __ ] are usually the
most craziest that's a Dark Arts bruh
people get caught up dude on that dust
son yo I've been on it man [ __ ] I'll get
you you were talking about like the
powder on drugs we have a friend that
did a bump accidentally because this
book accent damn so gently dude like a
stepdad because what happened was he
what he went to it he went to a club and
this girl came up to him and he's like a
super clean hears no [ __ ] right so she's
just dancing she thinks he's cute she's
like you want a bump what's up with a
bump with the bump it's a little bit of
coke a little story that he was like
what was that he goes yeah I just give
you a bump he starts freaking out no
give it mouth-to-mouth
no she's it was it's just nor did it was
fun yeah he was like what the [ __ ] was
that just give you a bump she wouldn't
explain it to him cuz she thought that
he knew he knew yeah but she was already
high so she does know what the [ __ ]
going on either but he started freaking
out he'd know what the hell is going on
with them yeah people are just free
it's super popular cocaine's super hot
right now oh yeah right now again really
always been on it no but I'm talking
about like its back huh
it's like it's like weed now you know
the Asian people do cocaine or not these
people do everything just Asian people
love drugs really dude there was a not
his mine I didn't know anything man do
you remember Harold and Kumar yeah you
remember that scene were like all the
Asian kids are [ __ ] really studious
and and at the after party real life why
the number one consumers a doubter oh
that's for sure oh really yeah the study
but is that like I thought easy people
were all were naturally just know what
was going on you know with the you know
class work yeah I mean there's that but
is there a new breed that are all doing
at it's always been like that
I think they were all magical and [ __ ] I
think we're just boring [ __ ] knowing
every day I mean I thought that they
yeah they got more knowledge it's not
like the [ __ ] light the 1960s white
guy back in the day they would just see
one Asian person like don't [ __ ] with
them he knows kung foo like we don't
know [ __ ] this guy knows school these
guys know Scoob
you thought we were wizards that's kind
of cool I wish to that's just in your
mind you at seven years old no kids I
would like watching David Blaine and
that people would always love it
oh my god no David leaves white you know
I think well I think oh is it it looks
black on middle-eastern he might be
middle-aged he might be Jewish might be
Israeli my B no he's tired he's been up
for 77 hours dude stunt
yeah those mediterranean dark circles
yeah I like how his magic trick is
insomnia pocus Porto Rican and Italian
his mom was Russian Jewish all of the
things that we need everybody you guys
are alright part of the dark art yeah
that's the dark arts dude yeah yeah I
remember the first time they had a rumor
that that an Asian kid near us right we
never seen an ageing of the town yeah so
it spread from town to town
hey there's finally a [ __ ] well we
saved that money me and to my buddy
saved up money to go see what yeah it
was a crawfish boil place no it was a um
you know what it was it was a pizza hut
somebody had like the roof somebody to
hit a pizza out with a truck or
something and the the roof on it had
fallen off and the Asian person was the
one that hit but anyway that's where the
rumor started somebody's like oh that's
some Asian people live in slidell and so
we went there and checked it out and
over this er rumors but we saw it a nice
time it was a really tight
we didn't see the Asian people wait
where did you come to LA in 2002 were
you like my years ago
like what or you already been around I'd
already got around a little bit I see so
but yeah growing up please didn't have a
lot of diversity you know we just had
like black and white
yeah so yeah when we got you know when
people were fired about that asian kid
that didn't happen you know I was kind
of a letdown after that but then they
had a Mexican kid that came to our
school in eighth grade and everybody was
just [ __ ] lost their mom you know
what so cause you had a mustache yo we
always talk about never seen a kid with
a mustache that's not true all my
Mexican friends in elementary school was
already starting to grow her hair and
[ __ ] I was like why period wives in
shape he had a job he had a job at night
like a full-time what do you want to do
after school I got to [ __ ] work hey
but you should come over sometime later
and then meet my kids
okay so you're eight
[Music]
[Music]